all right so it's time to talk
about everybody's favorite topic
oh no
Hey everybody and welcome to council of geeks
and I'm going to talk about today something that
the perspective that I'm coming at this from is
an lgbtq+ perspective, but I think it applies to
a lot of things outside of that. Which normally
is the case when I tackle these things. I have
a tendency to tackle things that you can
extrapolate and apply what I'm saying to
other areas or other groups as
well, at least in part. So I've had
this one on my to-do list for a while:
addressing the idea or the question of
why is the mere inclusion of certain groups of
people inherently considered to be political.
Now here's the funny thing about this topic...
I've been sitting on this for a while and
when I first jotted down the idea of in
some way tackling this what I thought I was
gonna be focusing on was talking about how
the inclusions of lgbtq+ people, disabled people,
neurodivergent people, racially diverse people
is not inherently political. Why the heck
do people feel the need to make it that?
But that's not where I'm going with this.
Because... well it IS political. But I think
there's still things for me to talk about there,
including covering why it is political. So first
of all, something that you need to accept going in
is that everything has a political aspect to it.
How much of that is intended or deliberate that
will vary, but there is always a political aspect
to everything. It does not matter what it is, even
if that political aspect is simply the mindset,
and the framework, and the understanding, and
base assumptions, and political background, and
inherent biases of the people creating the piece
of work. Whether it be the writer, directors,
whatever it is. Their political background and
understanding that influences what they do and how
they come at these things, even if those political
views are not directly injected into the work.
Everything, EVERYTHING, that is made to be
consumed including art - because I don't
care how artsy it is it's still intended to be
viewed by somebody - has a political aspect. And
if you are not prepared to accept that, I honestly
don't know how to have this conversation with you.
But assuming that you can go with me
that far, accepting that there is a
political element to everything, let's talk
specifically about the politics of inclusion
and why or at least my perspective on why (because
I'm not an expert) it is such a sticking point.
Especially in internet discourse and geek internet
discourse in particular much to my chagrin.
Well the first thing that really needs to be
addressed is in some ways the language. I run into
this every now and then, that sometimes part of
the problem is the way that we talk about things.
And just the fact that the term "political
correctness" exists is part of why people,
when they see inclusion, shake a finger and
go "POLITICS!" Because we actually have the
word political right in the thing that we use as
an umbrella that this sort of thing falls under.
Now "political correctness" was a term
originally coined in the 70s and originally
it was much more about the specifics about HOW
someone was portrayed, as opposed to their mere
inclusion and presence at all. But at this
point, especially in terms of popular use,
it absolutely all falls under that same umbrella.
But I kind of want to shove that term aside.
Forget the fact that the word "politics" exists
in this term. That is not what makes it political,
because that's just the language.
That's just what we use to describe it,
that does not inherently mean that word is
the best thing that we should be using or is
indicative of exactly what it is we're dealing
with. But as I said at the front end, inclusion
is political. Acknowledging the existence of a
group, especially a minority or underprivileged
or underrepresented group, is inherently a
political thing to do. Again, not always done
with a political intent. But including them
still makes some kind of political statement
about the work, or (if you're working in a piece
of fiction) about the world you have created.
I ran into this with the novel that I had my
kickstarter for. The Kickstarter's wrapped up
at this point, but I will put announcements out
when the book's eventually available for pre-order
and all that. I'm still working through a lot
of stuff, I've got a lot of things to do with
that. But in the process of working on that a very
interesting thing happened, especially once I got
it into the hands of my editor. Now when they were
going over it they took note, and what was great
was I didn't ask them to do this it's just part
of their process and it's actually part of why I
will highly recommend them as an editor once
they're free and available again. Or if they
are now. Teresa Grabs, you know what I'll
put a link in the description. They're great,
but the the thing is that I very deliberately
made some specific choices in terms of inclusions
of lgbtq+ characters, or at least ones that
could be read that way, and wanted that to be
part of the world that I was building. That was a
deliberate choice with a political element by me.
What Teresa ended up pointing out
to me was the fact that I had failed
to include anything that indicated there was
disability access. Because I had a couple of
locations where there were references to stairs
and no mention of ramps. Which means that without
meaning to, simply because I didn't think about it
and didn't account for it, I had created a world
where those specific locations (if not the society
and the world in general that I had depicted)
doesn't make accommodations
for physically disabled people.
And that has a political element because it means
that in the politics of this- well it meant BEFORE
I addressed it because I actually didn't want that
as a background element. But what it meant at the
time of that revision they looked at, it meant
that I had created a world where the political
choice had been made to not go out of the way
to accommodate these people in certain spaces.
That would have been, in-universe, a
political decision and my failure to
account for that had political implications and
made inferences about the world, even though I
didn't realize that I'd done that. Again tying
back to the fact that everything is political.
So now my decision to try and amend that and
include some references that make it clear
that at the very least some spaces are being
catered to for people with possible movement
disabilities. That is now in there and my decision
to include that is political, because it means
something in the context of the politics
of the world I have created for this book.
But here's the thing I REALLY want to
dig into. Because it is true inclusion
is political, but you know what we don't talk
about? We don't talk about the flip side of that.
Which is the fact that a LACK of inclusion is
also political. Generally speaking it is framed as
only being political when what are
considered to be minority groups
are depicted in a work. Be it film,
tv, video game, novel, whatever.
That is considered to be political but
because we don't say that same thing
about the inclusion of what is generally the
"default template"- and that template (in
western culture historically and still currently)
is generally male, white, heterosexual, cisgender,
and able-bodied. And we consider anything
that deviates on any of those five points,
or certainly if it deviates from all of them, to
be in a way political. But we don't talk about
there being politics behind someone who matches
all five. That's taken as a given, that is taken
as being apolitical. It's not and that's my big
frustration with this entire framing of including
people who aren't all five of those things is
in some way political. It fails to recognize the
fact that not including them is also political.
That's my big frustration more than anything else.
Because I'm not going to argue anymore, I may
have at one point, but I'm no longer going to
argue from the position of "including people
of other skin tones, or body sizes, or shapes,
or ability levels, or sexualities, or gender
identities isn't political." Because it is.
I am however immediately gonna push
back and say "so is not including them."
Everybody in every society has
their base assumptions, that's
why I brought up the issue of my failure to
account for disability in the world I created
in my novel. Because I'm an able-bodied person.
I've never had to deal with physical disability,
and so unless I really go out of my way
to account for it I don't think about it,
and therefore it's not there because that
is my normal. That is to me the default,
but just because it's my default doesn't rob it of
political implication. It's still there whether I
intend it or not, whether I recognize it or not,
whether I fully understand the meaning of those
implications or not. They are still present, they
are still there. Which is another element. When
people say well "I didn't want to be political,
so I just made everybody a white man." If somebody
does that, the fact that they think that makes it
apolitical is incredibly politically revealing.
About what they view as being normal
or what they view as the standard.
And your assumptions about what is normal,
what is standard, and what is a deviation or
an intrusion in from that is incredibly informed
by your political background, your political
understanding, your political biases, and your
political blind spots. Because we all have them.
Everybody has some area that is affected by
politics that we just don't understand, or don't
think to account for unless it's brought up by
somebody else. What that is will vary wildly. How
many blind spots people have that will also vary,
but we all have them. And that is why ultimately I
am 180 degrees in the opposite direction of where
I thought I was going to end up on this issue.
Which is not the position that I thought I would
be coming from, which is these "things are not
political, stop acting as if they are."
No, instead "these things ARE political,
stop acting as if their absence isn't political."
This ultimately is me venting a little bit at
the discourse. Which is ultimately me howling
into the wind. I understand that. I am a
small youtuber, I can't change the way
people are having these conversations.
And even setting aside bad actors who are going
to twist things for their own purposes anyways,
even people talking in good faith I can't control
that conversation. But I can still put this out
there and have it on the record: my stances on
these things and try to get people to understand
where I'm coming from. And maybe get them to
think about things in a way they didn't before.
The way I've had to do with lots of things in my
life, not just my creative works. There are lots
of things I've had to have my eyes opened about,
to realize that my assumption that "my normal
isn't political" is fundamentally wrong.
Nothing is apolitical. Deal with it.
So there you go. I don't know how much of this is
ultimately going to be helpful for other people,
or how much of it is just me doing this for
myself. But I hope you found that interesting,
thoughtful, entertaining, I don't know. Whatever
your thoughts are I hope you will drop something
down in the comments and allow us to talk
about it. Be respectful, that is my one
rule. I don't care what your position is,
if you're a jerk to me or anyone else you
will be gone. That's how it works. I have a
patreon which is how this channel is able to
exist and it's how I am able to eat. It's
what keeps the lights on around here,
and in addition to that there are all the usual
things that you can do to help me out as well.
Like, share, subscribe, and all those wonderful
things. Links down in the description. If you are
in need of an editor check out Teresa, they are
amazing, and all the other links besides for merch
and twitters and so forth. But you also don't
have to, because at the end of the day you are
the council and I am only running the meetings.
And until next time this council is adjourned.